we're already asking the question that's
going to be on everyone's mind once the
credits roll on Avengers endgame what's
next for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
only time will tell but like Doctor
Strange we've looked through 14 million
possible futures for the MCU and have a
few ideas and what we might see in phase
for those of you who are slightly less
obsessive about the MCU might be
wondering what exactly we mean by phase
four basically while each film walks a
delicate balance between being a
standalone feature and a part of a much
larger saga the MCU movies are
conceptually divided into phases the
idea is that while they might not
necessarily be direct sequels they each
tie into each other Thor matically and
build to a climax that unifies
everything that came before phase 1
which began with Iron Man in 2008 and
moved through movies like Captain
America the First Avenger Thor and often
overlooked Incredible Hulk was all about
introducing each of the superheroes on
their own before bringing them together
in the Avengers phase 2 was about
building a much larger universe around
them and reframing what a superhero was
by introducing cosmic heroes with vast
adventures like the guardians of the
galaxy and micro heroes with much
smaller scale adventures like ant-man
the matically the climax of phase 2 was
Avengers age of Ultron which also added
heroes like vision and the Scarlet Witch
to the team and then this phase 3 which
has been about lost and about the dire
consequences I can come from noble
intentions it began with the heroes
fighting each other in Captain America
Civil War and then moved through several
films about heroes discovering lives and
secrets in their past such as in Thor
Ragnarok and the black panther and in
Captain Marvel now it's set to reach its
end game in well and the game so what
happens in phase 4 the future is
shrouded in mystery but one thing you
can bank on is that the next few years
of the MCU are going to be focused on a
very different set of characters than
the last few part of that of course is
he inevitable product of the march of
time Chris Evans has mentioned that it
likes to be done with bug Busters and
focus on smaller projects at least for a
while and Robert Downey jr. has
expressed some similar desires to move
on from Tony Stark that makes sense too
because he's been at this for a while
even if you don't count cameos like the
one in Incredible Hulk and only focus on
the I am on movies and starring roles
are the Avengers films and spider-man
homecoming Downey has played Tony Stark
in nine Phil
over the course of 11 years Ironman
might be a character built for a median
that's meant to go on forever but at
some point you can't blame a guy for
wanting to take a break anybody on our
side hiding any shocking and fantastic
abilities they'd like to disclose I'm
open to suggestions
the flip side of that is that there's
some good news while Iron Man and
Captain America with a foundation of the
MCU for its first decade phase 3 went
hard introducing a whole new crop of
heroes
one of the biggest introductions came
when Marvel and Sony finally reached an
agreement to bring spider-man into the
MCU resulting in one of Marvel's best
films and homecoming if spider-man was
big though Black Panther and Captain
Marvel were downright massive both of
those films were the first solo outings
for their respective title characters
and both racked up over a billion
dollars at the box office
adding Doctor Strange and the MCU was
more than proven they can build an
entire new generation of superhero stars
to carry the torch interface for while
Marvel has said they won't be officially
announcing any phase 4 projects until
after spider-man far from home its
theaters in the summer of 2019 we do
know a few characters were likely to say
one is Adam warlock who has seized at
the end of guardians of the galaxy vol 2
he has traditionally been associated
with the Infinity stones
so listen clear what role he might play
in phase 4 but it has been previously
announced that he wouldn't be seen until
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 comes out
then there's the Eternals created by the
great Jack Kirby the Eternals is set to
star Angelina Jolie and features a group
of humans who long ago were experimented
on and given tremendous powers by the
cosmic space gods known as the
Celestials who previously cameoed in
guardians of the galaxy and finally
their shang-chi the master of Kung Fu
who is the world's greatest martial
artist in the comics shang-chi dedicated
his life to defeating the world
conquering plans of his father an
immortal Chinese villain the announced
MCU film is reportedly going to be
updated for modern audiences though so
just what roles shang-chi
or any of these new faces will play in
phase four is still unclear
one idea that's been touched on briefly
in the films as a concept of the legacy
character in the comics a legacy
character is one where new characters
take over existing superhero identities
once the original hero was moved on via
retirement or
Jim Rose was the second Ironman and both
Sam Wilson and Bucky Barnes have spent
time as Captain America you couldn't
have done that earlier
I hate here so far the only hints of
this in the MCU has been with ant-man
and the wasp with Scott Lang and hope
Van Dyne taking over those identities
from Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne
but if Chris Evans and Robert Downey jr.
do indeed hang up their spandex after
Avengers end game it's very possible we
may see Rhodey take over as Iron Man or
Bucky take over as Captain America after
all what better way to pay homage to the
founders of the MCU by making sure their
names live on forever one safe
assumption to make about the MCU going
forward is that whatever storyline
weaves through and unites the next 20
movies it won't be focused on Thanos and
the Infinity stones once you gather up
the six of them force them into a giant
golden gauntlet and kill half of the
universe after all there's really no way
to top air there's a reason beyond just
a logical progression of events that
leads us to think were going to be done
with the stones though Marvel Studios
president of production Kevin Feige
collectively referred to the first 22
MCU films as the Infinity Saga in
addition to being a nice designation to
fit on the side of a ridiculously
expensive box of blu-rays that's a
pretty clear indication that the stories
built around the stones are coming to an
end so what will the next MCU saga be
about luckily it turns out there are
plenty of possibilities one of the
things that makes it so difficult to
figure out what the Marvel movies are
going after endgame is that eliminating
the Infinity stones doesn't really
narrow down our options so what might
take that place in the comic book pages
Marvel has spent about sixty years
creating a nearly endless supply of
MacGuffins if you're not familiar with
the term a MacGuffin is a term for a
plot device that sparks the inciting
incident it's the thing that everyone's
looking for like the briefcase in Pulp
Fiction well The Maltese Falcon and The
Maltese Falcon
well like the six magic stones that
everyone in the MCU has been obsessing
about for the last decade luckily if
Marvel decides to go the MacGuffin route
again that there are plenty of
candidates for instance the dark hole
which is a user manual for black magic
and which appeared in season four of
agents of shield would be a natural
starting point for a saga involving
damaru the casket of ancient winters
which briefly appeared in the first
floor film can
the infinite power of nature then
there's the evil eye of Avalon the nega
bans us archers trailer-truck the list
is nearly endless with so many to choose
from it will probably go down to which
best fits the bad guys they want to use
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has had
more than its fair share of incredibly
powerful super villains from Loki and
Heller to Ultron and ego the Living
Planet but that's the nice thing about
superheroes they never seem to run out
of villains if Marvel decides to bring
in another cosmic threat like fan O's
Annihilus has one obvious candidate
there are also potentially more
interesting directions they could take
such as the time-traveling warlord Kang
the Conqueror or the world eaten
Galactus or they could go with a more
mystical threat such as de mama when it
comes right down to it there's really
just one big villain that stands out
above the rest the only thing is though
he comes with some baggage probably the
most exciting aspect of phase 4 is a
possibility that Marvel could finally
introduce MCU versions of some of their
most beloved heroes and villains
including the Fantastic Four and their
archenemy Doctor Doom
of course these characters have appeared
on film before three times in fact but
you can be forgiven for forgetting that
as most fans of the characters have
tried to convince themselves for years
that those movies were all just a bad
dream the three previous Fantastic Four
films are made by Fox now that Disney
has purchased Fox however the rights
have reverted to Marvel Studios giving
them a chance to finally get these
characters rights and as we saw with
spider-man homecoming nobody knows how
to do Marvel characters like Marvel
themselves as exciting as it would be to
finally see the Fantastic Four done well
though it's almost more exciting to
consider MCU versions of some of their
supporting cast including the enigmatic
Silver Surfer and Marvel's number one
super villain Doctor Doom
after all if Marvel can turn a talking
tree into a worldwide pop-culture icon
imagine what they can do with the
coolest villain in comics for a lot of
fans the Fantastic Four pale in
comparison to the big acquisition from
the Disney Fox do the x-men on their own
there are franchises about as massive
and complicated as the rest of the
Marvel Universe put together and they
also have their own sprawling mostly
successful film franchise the MCU so far
has gone out of its way to carve out a
world without mutants to the point of
referring to Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch by a similar but legally
distinct M word when they showed up at
the end of Captain America the Winter
Soldier this th miracle stop there's
nothing more horrifying America now that
Marvel has the rights to the x-men again
though they are free to introduce as
many mutants as they want or not as
we've learned from superhero films there
are an infinite number of ways you can
get superpowers so it's possible in the
MCU the x-men won't be mutants at all
and if the x-men do show up in the MCU
drawing phase 4
they might just wind up being used much
more sparingly than they have been in
their own film series if nothing else it
would allow fans who are still attached
to the Fox x-men series to have some
breathing room before we introducing
characters like storm or Jean Grey
whatever Marvel doesn't phase for though
one thing is guaranteed we'll be first
in line at the theater to find out see
you there
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite Marvel heroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]